Apple arcade is now available for iOS 13
so in this video will guide you through
everything you need to know about it
including how to sign up how to connect
the controller and how to cancel your
subscription and we'll also discuss if
it's actually worth five dollars a month
so let's get started you can find the
apple arcade tab within the app store
where you'll instantly see a bunch of
games to get started tap try it free for
a free one-month trial which you can
cancel at any time if you head to the
bottom of the Apple arcade tab you'll
see a full list of 59 games available at
launch and keep in mind that Apple will
continue to add more games in the coming
months with at least 100 in total you
can see a preview of each game and
you'll see which ones support
multiplayer how large the games are and
if they support controllers like the
Xbox one controller if you have one
here's how to connect it and use it to
play Apple arcade open the Settings app
on your iPhone tap on Bluetooth and make
sure it's enabled then grab your Xbox
one controller make sure it's charged
and turned on then press and hold the
pairing button on the top of the
controller your Xbox controller should
now show up on your iPhone tap on it and
you're done now head into a game that
supports controllers and boom the UI
switches to controller mode and it just
works and it works well the setup should
be basically identical with the
PlayStation 4 or MFI certified
controller games are downloaded straight
to the home screen just like any other
app now let's quickly run through my top
three favorite games that I've tried so
far on apple arcade the best one is
probably oceanhorn 2 which is an
adventure game that's very similar to
zelda the mechanics are absolutely
excellent and it works incredibly well
with the controller
I love that you can search the entire
map looking for hidden loot and treasure
chests with rare items combat is pretty
fun because it's actually challenging in
some areas of the game and the graphics
are amazing next up is lego brawler
which is very similar to Super Smash
Bros you can jump up and down platforms
and fight other brawlers with unique
abilities that you can pick up
throughout the map you can customize
your brawlers loadout with items that
you unlock from randomized chests that
you don't have to buy with in-app
purchases that's nice for a change it's
great because you can brawl with real
people from around the world by simply
tapping brawl or you
host your own game that comes with a
unique invite code that you can text to
your friends and either play two verse
two or four verse four matches it's a
pretty fun game especially if you're
very competitive with your friends in
fact there are many multiplayer games on
Apple arcade that allow you to connect
and play with real people around the
world which is a huge must for people
who don't like single-player games on to
my third favorite game card pocalypse
which is basically like the card game
hearthstone
except that it's mixed into an RPG that
has a character walking around their
school talking to other students
battling them and collecting cards for
your custom deck the game mechanics work
very well and basically just like
hearthstone but you can actually trade
cards with other characters so it's
pretty unique for RPG lovers I've
honestly only tried a few games so far
so I'm sure there are much better games
but I'm actually surprised because these
three games have been very polished and
I've been able to keep me busy for a few
hours so far so with that let's answer
the main question is Apple arcade worth
$5 a month well first off it's $5 for
the entire family up to six different
Apple accounts so if you have any kids
on your family plan that like video
games I would say that it's a hundred
percent worth it there are no ads your
kids have to deal with and no in-app
purchases so it could actually end up
being cheaper than a lot of free games
on the App Store that tempt you into
buying in-app purchases if you're a
casual user that plays games at least
once or twice a week I would say is
definitely worth getting Apple arcade as
a quick fix for when you're bored are
waiting somewhere like at the doctor's
office now if you're a hardcore gamer
that spends most of their time gaming
it's gonna be a hit or miss but there
are actually some really great games
like oceanhorn 2 that will give you
hours and hours of gameplay and there
are a huge list of achievements for a
lot of the games so if you're a sucker
for getting all of them
Apple arcade is a hundred percent worth
the money and it'll keep you busy for
months now if you absolutely must play
triple-a titles it may not be worth it
for you and if you're super competitive
online there are quite a few online
multiplayer games on Apple arcade so to
be completely honest after only playing
a few games I'm 100 percent sure that
it's worth $5 a month for a lot of
people not everyone but for a lot of
people you can cancel the subscription
at any
before a month passes so you don't get
charged at all so if you're getting
bored of Apple arcade here's how to
cancel it go to the Settings app on your
iPhone tap your name at the top of the
screen tap iTunes in app stores tap on
your Apple ID and tap view Apple ID
authenticate with your password or face
ID then scroll down and tap on
subscriptions apple arcade should show
up tap on it and finally tap cancel and
you're done overall I'd say that I'm
very impressed with how polished each
game has been they all work very well
and I haven't noticed any bugs yet there
are games for every age group starting
with Frogger for very young children and
up to games like oceanhorn 2 for teens
and adults who love adventure games like
Zelda and if you think about it some
people spend 30 to 60 dollars on a game
that they sometimes stop playing after
only 2 months I can honestly say that
even if you get bored of Apple arcade
two months later that $5 you've spent
after the free trial would be well worth
it so I've got to give props to Apple
for creating Apple arcade at such a
great price if you enjoy this video
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and check out
some of our iPhone 11 pro coverage right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video